A diagonalização quântica de Krylov, ou KQD para abreviar, refere-se à resolução de um problema de autovalor de matriz
projetando a matriz em um subespaço preparado num computador quântico, consistente com o método de Krylov, uma
abordagem poderosa da álgebra linear clássica. Ao longo deste vídeo, exploraremos para que o método de Krylov é útil,
e como e quando implementá-lo em computadores quânticos.
Então, o que é o método de Krylov? Suponha que temos uma matriz H relacionada a um problema científico ou empresarial, com n linhas e n
colunas. Estamos interessados no menor autovalor e₀ e no autovetor correspondente ψ₀. Vamos definir um
vetor inicial v, que pode ser motivado pela estrutura de H ou pode ser completamente aleatório. O subespaço de Krylov
de ordem r, que escrevemos como K_r, é gerado pela ação de H sobre esse
vetor inicial r menos uma vez, adicionando o resultado de cada ação subsequente de H
ao conjunto de vetores de abrangência. Ou seja, K_r é o espaço gerado pelos vetores v,
Hv, H² e assim por diante. Esses vetores geralmente não são ortogonais.
Classicamente, muitas vezes realizamos um processo de ortonormalização muito semelhante ao procedimento de Gram-Schmidt. Começas
normalizando o vetor inicial V e chamas o resultado de V₀. Depois, para o próximo vetor HV, subtrais sua
projeção em V₀ para tornar os dois vetores ortogonais. Em seguida, normalizas o resultado. Continuas assim,
agindo novamente com H e tornando o resultado ortogonal a todos os vetores adicionados anteriormente, até ter construído r
vetores ortonormalizados necessários para abranger o teu subespaço de Krylov de dimensão r.
Uma vez que tens esse subespaço, projetas a tua matriz sobre ele e diagonalizas a matriz projetada menor. Há
sutilezas e extensões, mas esse é o método de Krylov em seu nível mais simples.
Para entender melhor como isso funciona, vamos ver um exemplo trivial. Se H é essa matriz e V é escolhido como esse
vetor, então começaríamos normalizando V. Para gerar o segundo vetor num subespaço de Krylov, agimos
uma vez com H sobre o nosso vetor inicial e depois tornamos esse resultado ortogonal a V₀.
Um pouco de álgebra nos dá isso para V₁.
Isso não é útil para matrizes tão pequenas e normalmente não pararíamos numa dimensão de Krylov de dois. Mas se
fôssemos projetar H no nosso novo espaço de Krylov K₂, faríamos isso usando uma matriz V
que tem um vetor de Krylov para cada coluna e a sua conjugada transposta, que tem vetores de Krylov para linhas. Então
obteríamos esta matriz.
Essa matriz tecnicamente tem dimensão menor do que a nossa original. Obviamente, essa redução não é útil nessa
escala. Esse método é destinado a reduzir matrizes com muitos milhares ou até milhões de linhas e colunas
a apenas algumas. Então por que os métodos de Krylov são úteis? Acontece que essa simples prescrição
de ação do operador é muitas vezes a forma mais eficiente de se aproximar do estado de menor valor, ou estado fundamental, de uma
matriz operador. Vamos tornar isso um pouco mais explícito, embora deixemos a prova completa para o texto que acompanha o vídeo. Queremos
resolver um problema da forma H agindo sobre o vetor x nos dando uma constante vezes o vetor x. Vamos começar com um
chute para o nosso autovetor x₀. Esta é apenas uma solução aproximada. Ela tem um erro que chamamos de e₀. Agora queremos
fazer uma atualização desse chute, que chamaremos de x₁, esperando melhorar a nossa aproximação. Podemos expressar isso como
o x₀ original mais alguma correção p₀, que ainda está por ser determinada. Podemos
repetir esse processo iterativamente, adicionando cada vez mais vetores de correção pᵢ.
Obviamente, queremos que o nosso erro seja reduzido, mas não é apenas o estado que nos importa. Também nos importamos com a
ação de H sobre esse estado. Então a quantidade que realmente queremos minimizar é a norma-H desse erro, ou a norma da
ação de H sobre esse erro.
Agora podemos ver que essa é uma expressão envolvendo p₀ e podemos nos perguntar quais escolhas de p minimizam
essa norma-H do erro com mais eficiência. De qual espaço devemos selecionar a correção? Sob certas
condições, como quando H é simétrico e positivo definido, escolher as primeiras r correções dentro de K_r
se mostra ótimo. Em termos mais simples, precisamos de alguma forma de preparar um bom subespaço no qual
possamos projetar o nosso Hamiltoniano. E em muitos casos, o subespaço de Krylov é o espaço gerado pelos vetores das correções mais
eficientes ao nosso chute inicial.
Para uma prova real, veja o texto que acompanha este vídeo.
Tudo o que descrevemos até agora pode ser feito classicamente. Então, como e quando usaríamos um computador quântico?
Para matrizes muito grandes, o método de Krylov pode exigir longos tempos de computação e grandes quantidades de memória. O tempo
necessário para a operação matricial de H sobre V escala como N² no pior caso.
E isso é feito para cada vetor que queremos no nosso subespaço. A dimensão do subespaço r normalmente não é uma fração significativa
de N e frequentemente escala como log de N. Então gerar todos os vetores escala
como da ordem de N² log N.
Embora haja outras etapas, como a ortonormalização, este é o escalonamento dominante a ter em mente.
A computação quântica nos permite mudar quais atributos do problema determinam o escalonamento do tempo e dos recursos
necessários. Em vez de dependência do tamanho da matriz n de forma generalizada, veremos coisas como o número de shots e
o número de termos de Pauli não comutativos que compõem um Hamiltoniano.
Vamos explorar como isso funciona.
Lembre que o operador que evolui temporalmente um estado quântico é a exponencial de iH sobre ħ. E é
muito comum, especialmente na computação quântica, omitir o ħ da notação.
Uma forma de entender e até realizar essa função exponencial de um operador é observar a sua expansão em série de Fourier.
Nota que essa operação agindo sobre algum vetor inicial V produz uma soma de termos
com potências crescentes de H aplicadas ao estado inicial. Parece que podemos simplesmente construir o nosso subespaço de Krylov fazendo a evolução temporal
do nosso estado de chute inicial. E isso é quase verdade. O problema está em
realizar a evolução temporal num computador quântico real. Muitos dos termos no Hamiltoniano não comutam entre
si. Então, enquanto alguns operadores exponenciais simples como e elevado a −iZ correspondem a circuits simples,
Hamiltonianos gerais não e, como contêm termos não comutativos,
não podemos simplesmente decompor a exponencial num produto de termos simples como fazemos com números. Então
isso não é trivial, mas é um processo bem estudado na computação quântica. Realizamos a evolução temporal
em computadores quânticos usando um processo chamado trotterização, que por si só é um assunto rico. Mas, num nível muito alto,
ao dividir a evolução temporal em pequenos passos, digamos M passos, limitamos os efeitos da não-comutatividade dos
termos. Vamos chamar o subespaço de Krylov de ordem r que geramos no contexto clássico usando potências de H
diretamente de subespaço de Krylov de potência K_PR.
Agora geramos um espaço semelhante usando o operador de evolução temporal unitário u dado pela exponencial de iHt.
Chamaremos isso de espaço de Krylov unitário K_UR.
O subespaço de Krylov de potência K_PR que usamos classicamente não pode ser gerado diretamente num computador quântico, pois H
não é um operador unitário. Pode-se mostrar que usar o subespaço de Krylov unitário fornece garantias de convergência semelhantes
às do subespaço de Krylov de potência.
Especificamente, o erro do estado fundamental converge eficientemente desde que o estado inicial V tenha sobreposição com o
verdadeiro estado fundamental que não seja exponencialmente pequena, e desde que haja uma lacuna suficiente entre os auto-
estados. Aqui as potências de u se tornam diferentes passos de tempo. A k-ésima potência de u avança
o tempo por k * dt.
Podemos rotular o elemento do subespaço que evoluiu temporalmente por um tempo total k·dt como s sub k. Podemos projetar o nosso
Hamiltoniano H no subespaço de Krylov unitário K_UR. Em outras palavras,
calculamos cada elemento de matriz de H na base K_UR. Chamaremos essa
matriz projetada de H til. Os elementos de matriz de H til são dados por esses valores esperados, que podem ser
estimados usando o computador quântico.
Lembre que H pode ser escrito como uma soma de operadores de Pauli em diferentes qubits e que nem todos os operadores de Pauli
podem ser medidos simultaneamente. Podemos separar os termos de Pauli em grupos de termos comutativos e medir todos eles
de uma vez. Mas podemos precisar de muitos desses grupos para cobrir todos os termos. Então o número de grupos comutativos distintos nos quais
os termos podem ser particionados, n_GCP, se torna importante. Se usarmos um subespaço de Krylov unitário de dimensão r, a
matriz resultante terá dimensões r × r. Se r for muito menor que n, então fizemos
progresso útil, e tipicamente r é muito menor que 100, o que significa que podemos diagonalizar isso facilmente num computador clássico.
Mas lembre que s_n e s_m geralmente não serão ortogonais. Às vezes é
possível diagonalizar uma matriz numa base não ortogonal. Mas há razões numéricas e físicas para
primeiro mudar para uma base ortogonal. Portanto, resolvemos um problema generalizado de autovalor usando a matriz de Gram S.
O elemento mn da matriz de Gram é dado pelo produto interno de s_m com s_n.
Tanto os elementos de H til quanto os de S são calculados usando um teste de Hadamard.
O problema generalizado de autovalor se torna então este.
Como observado acima, a dimensão do subespaço de Krylov unitário R é exponencialmente menor que a nossa dimensão
de matriz inicial N. Portanto, esse problema de autovalor é simples de resolver classicamente.
Resumindo: começamos com um estado de referência, depois o evoluímos por diferentes períodos de tempo para gerar o
subespaço de Krylov unitário. Projetamos o nosso Hamiltoniano nesse subespaço e também estimamos as sobreposições dos
vetores do subespaço. Por fim, resolvemos o problema generalizado de autovalor de dimensão menor classicamente. Vamos comparar o que
determina os custos computacionais de usar a técnica de Krylov classicamente e quanticamente. Esboçamos isso
já para a versão clássica e não há analogias perfeitas entre as abordagens clássica e quântica para todas as etapas. Mas esta tabela reúne alguns
escalamentos de diferentes etapas para consideração. Lembre que os Hamiltonianos geralmente têm termos que não podem ser medidos simultaneamente porque não
comutam. Separamos os termos do Hamiltoniano em grupos de operadores de Pauli comutativos que podem ser todos medidos simultaneamente e podemos precisar de muitos
desses grupos para contabilizar todos os termos que não comutam. Construir H til num computador quântico requer
medições separadas para cada grupo de cadeias de Pauli comutativos no Hamiltoniano. E cada um deles requer muitos shots. Devemos fazer isso para r²
elementos de matriz diferentes, correspondentes a r² combinações de diferentes fatores de evolução temporal. Há
às vezes formas de reduzir isso. Mas neste tratamento aproximado, o tempo necessário para isso escala aproximadamente como
o número de shots vezes o número de grupos de termos de Pauli comutativos vezes r².
Os elementos de S devem ser estimados, o que escala como o número de shots
vezes r³. Vemos que a diagonalização quântica de Krylov pode ser útil em casos onde o número de grupos de Pauli comutativos
no Hamiltoniano é relativamente pequeno.
Essa dependência de escalonamento sugere algumas aplicações onde o método de Krylov pode ser útil e outras onde provavelmente
não será. Alguns Hamiltonianos têm alta complexidade quando mapeados para qubits, envolvendo muitas cadeias de Pauli não comutativos
que não podem ser facilmente particionadas em poucos grupos comutativos.
Isso é muitas vezes verdade para problemas de química quântica. Por exemplo, essa complexidade apresenta dois desafios primários para
computadores quânticos de curto prazo. Primeiro, a estimativa de cada elemento de H til se torna computacionalmente cara devido ao
grande número de termos. Segundo, os circuits de Trotter necessários se tornam proibitivamente profundos. Ambos os pontos
serão menos problemáticos quando os computadores quânticos atingirem tolerância a falhas, mas devem ser considerados no curto prazo. Mesmo sistemas com mapeamentos mais simples
do que os da química quântica podem enfrentar os mesmos impedimentos se os Hamiltonianos tiverem termos não comutativos demais.
O método de Krylov é mais útil onde o Hamiltoniano pode ser particionado em relativamente poucos grupos de Pauli comutativos
e onde H é fácil de implementar em circuits de Trotter. Ambas as condições são satisfeitas, por
exemplo, para muitos modelos de rede de interesse na física. O KQD é especialmente útil se muito pouco é conhecido sobre o
estado fundamental. Isso decorre das suas garantias de convergência inerentes e da sua aplicabilidade em cenários onde
métodos alternativos são inviáveis devido ao conhecimento insuficiente do estado fundamental.
Embora o KQD seja uma ferramenta poderosa, os aspectos demorados do protocolo — particularmente a estimativa de cada
elemento do Hamiltoniano projetado e a sobreposição dos estados de Krylov — representam oportunidades de melhoria.
Uma abordagem alternativa envolve aproximar o estado de Krylov usando circuits de Trotter, depois amostrando o
estado aproximado para obter uma projeção na base computacional e, em seguida, projetando H no subespaço
gerado por esses estados da base computacional.
Em casos onde é aplicável, essa metodologia, conhecida como diagonalização quântica de Krylov baseada em amostragem, SKQD,
potencialmente oferece reduções significativas nos requisitos de tempo e recursos em comparação com o KQD tradicional.
A integração das técnicas de subespaço de Krylov com métodos de amostragem no SKQD representa uma fronteira empolgante nos
algoritmos quânticos.